>> WELCOME TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY."
THE LIBERAL POLICIES FAILING
AMERICA.
I'M TAMMY BRUCE AND FOR SEAN AND
BREAKING TONIGHT, NEW TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS FROM EIGHT AFRICAN
COUNTRIES TO THE UNITED STATES
HAVE BEEN PUT INTO PLACE AND THE
SPECULATION ABOUT A NEW COVID
VARIANT.
WE WILL HAVE FULL COVERAGE LATER
IN THE SHOW.
AND ALSO I HAD COME OF THE
DEVASTATING CONSEQUENCES OF
LEFT-WING CRIME POLICIES ARE
MORE UNDENIABLE THAN EVER.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THE TAPES.
BUT FIRST, TONIGHT, THE EVER
STRUGGLING JOE BIDEN IS FINDING
NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS TO SHOW
JUST HOW OUT OF TOUCH, OUT OF
POCKET, AND FRANKLY OUT OF STEAM
HE REALLY IS.
HEADING OFF TO A BILLIONAIRE'S
HOME THIS WEEK FOR THE
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY, EXPOSING
ONCE AGAIN HIS OUTER DISCONNECT
FROM THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
DISCONNECT FROM COMMON SENSE
AMERICANS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND GET THIS, AMID SLUMPING
APPROVAL, MASSIVE POLICY
FAILURES, AND A NEVER ENDING
STREAM OF BAFFLING MOMENTS,
STILL UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
"AMERICA IS BACK."
TAKE A LOOK.
TO SPEAK A HOLD ON, MY PHONE IS
RINGING.
LOOK AT HIS CALLING!
HELLO?
HELLO MR. PRESIDENT?
DR. BIDEN -- MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT
HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO YOU.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, WE HAD A
NEW YORK FIREFIGHTER HERE.
IT IS SO GOOD -- IT'S GOOD FOR
YOU CALLING.
WE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO THE
AMERICAN FOLKS ON THIS
THANKSGIVING DAY?
>> MY MESSAGES AFTER TWO YEARS,
WE ARE BACK KHMER AMERICAS BACK,
THERE'S NOTHING WE ARE UNABLE TO
OVERCOME.
>> Tammy: THERE YOU GO.
BUT OF COURSE, THE DEMOCRAT
AGENDAS ON A BRUTAL ATTACK.
FOR EXAMPLE, LOOK AT THIS
BIZARRE TWEET FROM
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN BLAMING
BUSINESSES FOR RISING PRICES
INSTEAD OF HER OWN PARTY'S
RECKLESS POLICIES TWEETED
"AMERICANS ARE GETTING RECORD
HIGH PRICES FOR THEIR
THANKSGIVING TURKEY WHILE BIG
POULTRY COMPANIES ARE PAYING
BILLIONS IN DIVIDENDS GIVING
CEOs RAISES AND EARNING HUGE
PROFITS."
AT THAT PROMPTED A WAVE OF
MOCKERY FROM THE LEFT AND RIGHT
ALIKE.
AND MEANWHILE, THE OPTIMISM THIS
WEEK AHEAD A DECADE LOW AND THE
WALL STREET FEAR INDEX TODAY,
YES, WE HAVE ONE, HAD ITS
HIGHEST LEVEL IN TEN MONTHS.
ADD THAT TO THE RISING GAS
PRICES AND EVEN A CHRISTMAS TREE
SHORTAGE.
AS THE AMERICAN CHRISTMAS TREE
ASSOCIATION IS WARNING THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES AND WHETHER
PROBLEMS MEANS THAT SOME TREES
WILL BE IN SHORT SUPPLY.
SO TONIGHT, THE BIDEN-HARRIS
AGENDA IS FAILING, LITERALLY ON
EVERY FRONT.
INFLATION IS SURGEON, THE BORDER
IS STILL A MESS.
AMERICAN ADVERSARIES ARE
EMBOLDENED.
ALL WHILE DEMOCRATS ARE STILL
EAGER TO HAVE US WALK OFF A
RECKLESS FAR LEFT SPENDING
CLIFF.
ON THEIR SO-CALLED BUILD BACK
BETTER AGENDA.
BUT ASK YOURSELF, IS THERE ONE
POLICY BEING PUSHED BY THE LEFT
THAT IS ACTUALLY FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS?
ROLLING BACK ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
MEANS MORE PAIN AT THE GAS PUMP.
MORE GOVERNMENT DEPENDENCE AND
LESS OPTIMISM ABOUT FINDING
WORK.
AND WEAK ON CRIME POLICIES ARE
MAKING COMMUNITIES LESS AND LESS
SECURE ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT'S DANGEROUS AND